so I just wanted us all to kind of
connect and get on the same page in
terms of what the communication plan is
for when we announced Fusion Arena but I
figured before we dive into this we
could watch the final video rate to the
top of the reddit this is going to be
the first stadium built just for video
games in the United States and they're
building it in Philadelphia a town known
for its well passionate fans in fact
here is where the Eagles play and that's
the Phillies stadium the fusion arena as
it will be called will be right in the
center of Philadelphia sports this is
the story of how Comcast is building on
the passion of Philadelphia sports fans
to create a global eSports juggernaut
leading that endeavor is this man
Tucker Roberts and it's worth noting
that he's not just any casually dressed
executive he also happens to be the son
of Comcast's CEO Brian Roberts and
grandson of Ralph Roberts the co-founder
of the company which is now worth nearly
200 billion dollars I've been a gamer
all my life much to the chagrin of my
parents and my grades but when online
gaming started that really was a game
changer for me in terms of connecting
people to other people I thought was so
fascinating and now everybody plays
video games today in every single
country and so when you think about how
big is that business opportunity you
know it could be the biggest one of all
them Comcast is doing a growing field of
media and sports Titans that are
investing in eSports including Michael
Jordan Dallas Cowboys owner Jerry Jones
and Atlanta's Cox Communications but the
company isn't new to sports
entertainment the USA's largest cable
provider has invested heavily in sports
throughout the years just look at their
flagship market of Philadelphia where
it's nearly impossible to separate
comcast from the local sports teams
Comcast owns broadcasting rights to
nearly all Philly's Sixers and flyers
games and even has full ownership of the
Flyers and their stadium the Wells Fargo
Center traditional sports or sports in
general is you know is the DVR proof
event of our time and it always kind of
will Stan
test the time this is Joe Marsh he's the
chief business officer for this new
division of Comcast and believes eSports
can be a large part of the company's
business in terms of what gaming can be
for a Comcast Spectacor in the company I
really think it could be a building to
our business to put that in perspective
after 50 years they're ice hockey
franchise the Flyers have yet to hit
evaluation over a billion dollars
Comcast investment in eSports began in
2017 when they purchased the overwatch
league franchise for twenty million
dollars borrowing the color scheme of
the Flyers they name the team the fusion
and began to try to build a fan base we
were starting as a non-endemic team with
zero followers so how do you build a fan
base from from thin air without making
it inauthentic because you can buy fans
and you can buy gather that's not how we
were gonna build our team most of the
players to the fusion live here in this
large suburban home outside of LA decked
out with overwatch imagery gaming pcs
and even a personal chef the biggest
thing I think we've done especially
around our content is that the branding
and the imagery you see of our team is
very Philly centric it's very Philly
based even though the team is made up of
mostly international players the fusions
YouTube channel is filled with videos of
players wearing Philadelphia team shirts
opening care packages of Tastykake and
Wawa coffee and yes even gritty makes an
appearance well how this content isn't
about the game it's about the players
themselves eSports fans want to see
everything our guys do what they ate for
breakfast chef Heidi's posting that on
Twitter if they hit the gym or laying
around with the soccer net you know the
difference of eSports and regular sports
is you can see yourself in the fusion
players we want to give you that access
to feel like you're part of the team
because you know one day you could be
and and and that's the dream that we're
trying to help foster would also help
their popularity was winning
the fusion became that underdog team
that worked its way from the bottom of
the playoffs all the way to the finals
and even though the team lost to the
London based franchise their fans were
there to support them 15,000 people or
so to hurt the finals cheering as the
fusion come out and my family got to be
there with me which is really special it
was a surreal experience for me to go
wow this is you know it went from fights
about the Wi-Fi you know 2:00 a.m. when
I was in middle school to you know Here
I am and they're all cheering for my
team this is a chance tucker succeeds
his father at the top of comcast someday
much as brian took over from his dad 17
years ago but that's getting ahead of
things there are more pressing concerns
while overwatch enjoyed initial success
with its release in 2016
it's average views on twitch decreased
over time and when we visited a regular
season match at Blizzard Arena in
Burbank California
the 530 seat theater was less than half
full on a Friday night but Tucker is
still betting on the side of eSports and
nowhere is that more apparent than the
50 million dollar investment in the
fusion arena set to break ground in the
next few months so the fusion arena is
going to be the first of its kind it's
it's going to be in my opinion the best
arena for eSports in North America it'll
be a 3,500 capacity purpose-built venue
it's going to be kind of like an EDM
concert but you're gonna be watching the
fusion while the fusion arena bears the
name of their overwatch team it serves a
purpose beyond just that game for
Comcast it's a long-term play to reach a
global audience there's a global market
that will benefit from this gaming hub
being built in Philadelphia it's an
attractive place for a lot of games to
have their events you're gonna be able
to get viewership in the West Coast but
also in Europe and you're gonna be able
to do it at a fraction of the cost of
some of the other cities on the East
Coast and after a recent joint venture
with SK Telecom
South Korea's largest wireless carrier
and owner of a wildly successful eSports
team
Comcast hopes to diversify their
foothold in multiple games the new
entity t1 entertainment and sports
expands their game portfolio into some
of the most popular sports franchises
League of Legends hearthstone pub G and
more really what we're gonna do there is
enhance everything that our South Korean
counterparts have done and now the plan
is to take that model and go global with
it but for now the fusion arena is still
just a parking lot across the street
from the Eagles stadium a new report
puts global eSports revenue at just over
1 billion dollars this year in
comparison global revenue for the
traditional leagues and teams is around
a hundred billion dollars and if you
include all the industry around those
sports revenue is estimated to be over a
trillion dollars so if Tucker wants to
make his mark on his family's business
with a global eSports Empire one that
could even rival their traditional
sports empire it's gonna take time and
for it to work a whole new community of
sports fans will need to emerge to build
in a gaming arena in South Philadelphia
kind of legitimizes what we're doing
look we're right in the heart of South
Philadelphia Sports Complex I'm a huge
Philly sports fan so it's really a dream
come true to work on something that
represents the city there's such a
strong community within our fusion
Dischord they're they're coming up with
events sometimes even without us just
saying hey who wants to meet up you know
over here in place and games or go to
this movie together and so the fact that
we've fostered that in any small way is
is really awesome to see and makes
everything worth it